así lucen hoy las aulas de la escuela
Abdul rahim shahit en kabul desde que
volvieron a tomar el poder en agosto del
año pasado los talibanes prohibieron a
las niñas acceder a educación intermedia
y secundaria y ahora que también se les
impidió Ingresar a las universidades el
futuro de las mujeres de Afganistán
preocupa más que nunca eso me entristece
mucho porque todas las mujeres afganas
que conforman la mitad de la sociedad
del país eran analfabetas en el futuro Y
en segundo lugar no sé cómo seguir
adelante con nuestras vidas y alimentar
a nuestras familias hasta hoy solo las
niñas pueden asistir a la escuela
primaria pero muchos temen que esto
pueda cambiar en el corto plazo y que no
les sea posible continuar con sus
estudios después de las vacaciones de
invierno se nos debe permitir ir a las
escuelas hemos hecho algo malo queremos
ser educadas para los talibanes los
derechos de las niñas y los niños no son
iguales
a pesar de que habían prometido ser más
flexibles los talibanes han reforzado su
dura interpretación del islam que marcó
su primer periodo en el poder entre 1996
y 2001
pensé que estaba haciendo algo bueno
pero ahora veo que los talibanes nos
dicen que todos estos once años de
enseñanza fueron un pecado que cometí no
veo ninguna religión o cultura que diga
que enseñar aprender y educarse es un
pecado más las restricciones a las
mujeres se han multiplicado en los
últimos meses además de impedir su
entrada a parques y gimnasios en su más
reciente medida los talibanes les
prohibieron trabajar para ong nacionales
y extranjeras lo que amplía la exclusión
en la mayoría de los campos de empleo